alors serge lama comme vous êtes passés
pas loin de la mort lors de votre
accident je vais vous faire une
interview jugement dernier c'est normal
serge lama
a dû voler de l'argent dans le porte
monnaie de ta maman quand tu étais petit
jamais il a volé jamais fait pour piquer
de l'argent à ma mère c'était compliqué
vous savez les titres et provinces et
puis je piquais les sucres serge lama
as-tu copié sur ton voisin en classe
pendant les compos oui
as-tu enfermait des élèves du sexe
féminin dans les cabinets
non
non mais j'avais déjà fait une sale
manie quand j'étais à la maternelle
neuve pas déjà mais je je piquais des
petites filles avec des épingles
et serge lama est ce que tu te reposes
pour ça oui ah oui oui serge lama
as-tu par donner à ta mère oui
serge lama
as tu déjà été tentée par
l'homosexualité
non et j'avais mon meilleur ami qui
était homosexuel et quand comme ça a
marché très mal quand j'étais môme avec
les avec les jeunes filles un jour
j'arrive et puis je dire j'en ai j'en ai
plein monde je vais me taire [ __ ] j'en ai
marre mbia mon pauvre caucourt on peut
pas voir toutes les chansons même temps
serge lama as-tu fait l'amour sans désir
de progrès oui quelle honte
tu te reposes je dirais même que des
fois je les fais volontairement pour ne
pas procréer
serge lama as-tu trompeta femmes
et
c'est ta dernière chance serge lama
ça le jugement dernier
c'est d'entrer au paradis
et avec ma femme c'est entrer au paradis
serge lama as-tu trompeta maîtresse ans
a
fui ma femme comédie serge lama
tu vraiment fréquenter les petites
femmes de pigalle et bah non non moi je
suis plutôt un type à bourgeoise oui je
suis un peu non j'aime oui serge lama tu
préfères les femmes mariées oui comme ça
tu les as pas sur le dos toute la
journée
pas forcément mariés mais aussi oui
d'accord serge lama a tué exiger des
femmes des pratiques contre nature
j'ai pas exigée mais je leur ai demandé
quoi gentiment elles ont dit oui pas
tout
l'interview jugement dernier on a beau
shooting
[Applaudissements]
donc tu es mort c'est ce qui m'a tuer
devant dieu des as tu voler de l'argent
dans le porte monnaie de ta maman quand
tu étais petit ouais
je les fais à cause de dostoïevski un
livre qui fait rimer châtiment bah oui
parce que je me dis est ce que je suis
capable comme raskolnikov ce que je vais
craquer moi aussi j'ai craqué et j'ai
dit à maman mais qu'il était perdu et
j'ai dit c'est là je vais retrouver
l'argent donc j braves comme des
tuques au pied sur ton voisin en classe
pendant les compositions non non c'était
plutôt les voisins gay au pied ce mois
en toute modestie à tous vos listes
tuant fermé et tes camarades dans les
cabinets de l'école
non mais je me suis fait je me suis fait
prendre avec un camarade dans la cabane
de l'école
c'est ok parce que nous étions il y en a
un qui est portée aux chocs il a joué au
bridge à l'école mais le problème des
bridges sur le mur et on est allés à
deux postes de résoudre le problème va
faire croire ça aux profs
c'est la stricte vérité c'est la tête de
ma mère on peut dire à corti qu'ils
arrêtent de fumer derrière
à sfax et thierry mon deuil quand as tu
refuses allons devoir conjugal en
prétextant une migraine non mais je suis
parfois fatigué
day c'était il le jugement dernier mais
as-tu déjà trompé ton compagnon
dans la tête et jamais
des as tu utilisé sa notoriété pour
séduire pour peter
dave as-tu consommer des substances
aphrodisiaques en y prenant du plaisir
tout est là dans le jeu mangini
gingembre s'en fait partie si ça marche
ça marche ah bon
tu es tu vivras ensuite des actes que la
morale réprouve mal de quel pays
day
regrettes-tu d'avoir accepté que ta mère
soit euthanasié
aulas j'ai eu des doutes émis des doutes
et ce même pour ça qu'on l'a fait
autopsié quand on a vu qu'il y avait
vraiment des métastases partout et bien
non on n'a pas le regretter à la vérité
il est là alors
connaît l'histoire du nec justement qui
meurt et qui a ré décent et à droite il
ya une salle événement il ya le feu
partout maman comment s'imaginer en
faire et à gauchy remake à manger avec
des énormes plus tard il a le droit de
choisir tu vois alors évidemment il
s'agit là ça avec d'énormes pétards et
seulement j'y prends du nom un peu tard
il y quelques mois le feu non ça c'est
l'autre sage
[Musique]
titoff oui quand j'étais petit as tu
essayé de regarder sous le bureau de la
maîtresse pour voir sa culotte
ouais
mais justement c'était ça le problème
c'est qu'on en voyait que la culotte en
fait titeuf
as-tu enfermer des élèves de sexe
féminin
dans les cabinets mais ça donc je le
faisais pas petit mais maintenant
j'essaye des fois d'enfermer les nanas
dans les chiottes est ce que tu te robe
pas anti tough sur sa non mais tu
n'entrera pas au paradis ah merde
titoff oui plus récemment à tuer
utiliser ta notoriété
pour obtenir des avantages particuliers
oui je peux répondre à sa place ou moins
grave grave fut les gags en boîte mais
comme sahin carré viiip je regarde jeu
mais là je fais coucou à tout le monde
grave et tu obtiens les avantages
particuliers a déjà servi qu'à faire le
guet c'est super mais tu t'en rends bien
sur obiwi 42 toit en gironde titoff dans
ces cas là as-tu exigé de tes
partenaires des pratiques contre nature
contre nature non jamais jamais t'es con
titoff ces actes délictueux ont ils
étaient accompagnés par l'absorption de
substances illicites way jamais jamais
titoff oui dans ces cas là quand tu as
pris ces substances ne t'appartient plus
il m'appartient
peter oui parce que tu as pris ces
substances illicites tu ne t'appartient
plus est ce que tu penses que l'on
puisse aimer une femme
et la tâche et la foule était
justement passé parce qu'on aime si on
fait ça si tu veux entrer au paradis
titeuf dis moi maintenant je me repens
je me repassais
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
ça twitter gérard jugnot
as-tu voler de l'argent dans le
porte-monnaie de ta maman quand tu étais
petit jamais jamais vaincu jamais à bord
n'est pas d'argent dans porte-monnaie
demande ça c'est une chose gérard jugnot
as-tu enfermer des élèves de sexe
féminin dans les cabinets de l'école
malheureusement non non non ce masculin
masculin oui
gérard jugnot
têtu tripoter dans les chiottes du lycée
avec des copains on s'embête arriver oui
mais pas de copie n'est pas comme
gérard jugnot jean paradis si tu te
repent à l'époque dans les chiottes du
lycée avec tes copains y at il eu
pénétration au nom non
lors de
cette session faire écouter mettra sion
ne dit pas je ne mange pas de ce mandat
si je peux pas mal à ses créations
gérard jugnot tam dit
gérard jugnot oui pendant ses vacances à
royan
têtu masturber en pensant à anet
[ __ ] mais qu'on doit il sait pas pas
là mais
sans doute oui amor amor
gérard
regrettes-tu d'avoir été aussi lourd
dans ce club de vacances en tunisie pour
obtenir de cette malheureuse ta première
pénétration
je me souviens pas
je ne me souviens pas mon père rousse
est allé moi
souvient et
regrette d'avoir été aussi lourd pour
obtenir dans cette malheureuse je suis
prêté lourd j'étais léger gérard balance
parce qu'elle est la
tante encelade est-il si je te
gérard jugnot
tu as fumé temps premiers pétards aux
usa avec clavier et l'ermite
souhaites-tu la même chose pour ton fils
arthur s'était pas le premier mais c'est
quasiment le dernier parce que je j'ai
eu des hallucinations
c'était très fort c'est parce qu'il y
avait là dedans j'ai vu des mecs avec
des canons sciés sortir des détails y
est j'ai hurlé je vous annonce quatre
ans non
je touche pas ça moi je passe trop
fragile très fragile gérard jugnot
tu n'aimes pas les hallucinations non
non tu as tort
georges in you we had
profiter de ta notoriété pour séduire
pas assez
mais j'avais des sosies qui s'en
servaient à dallas mais
as-tu déjà profité de sa notoriété pour
demander aux femmes des choses contre
nature
c'est pas osé mais sera du
c'est un peu tard gérard jugnot je fais
une faveur à
exister une migraine pour échapper au
devoir conjugal
non
gérard jugnot as tu déjà fait l'amour
vous sans réel désir de procréer
a tout le temps
gérard jugnot
as tu déjà trompé ta maîtresse
non
à
jean louis murat
c'est le jugement dernier mais j'en ai
eu ras vous pensé à la mort une
demi-heure par jour
ah bon donc vous êtes prêts pour
l'interview jugement dernier
jean louis murat quand tu étais petit
as tu essayé de regarder sous le bureau
de ta maîtresse
jamais
il était plein
as-tu enfermer des élèves de sexe
féminin dans les cabinets jamais il
était en plein air
jean louis durand
as-tu jouer au docteur avec tes copains
jamais il n'était jamais malade c'est
bien merci
jean louis murat avec ce professeur
d'anglais qui t'a fait lire coridon es
tu sûr qu'il ne sais vraiment rien passé
sexuellement tu es bien bien sûr que non
jean louis murat
as-tu utiliser ta notoriété pour obtenir
des avantages particuliers
des fois les bonnes places pour les
autres ça absorbe le tue encore des
substances illicites jamais
jamais jamais tu as chopin justement
c'est bien correct on tente purgatoire
un éventuel m'est étranger
est il arrivé d'avoir envie de la femme
d'un autre
jamais gêné principe
est il arrivé de trompeta fable jamais
gêné principe est il arrivé de trompeta
maîtresse
c'est jamais une maîtresse
jean louis murat as tu ne serait ce
qu'une fois
emmerder le monde par plaisir
jamais
[Applaudissements]
patrick bruel oui quand tu étais petit a
tué regarder sous le bureau de la
maîtresse pour voir sa culotte
oui mais pas petit un peu plus tard
en troisième le professeur d'espagnol au
lycée henri iv voilà j'ai tout dit ces
deux jugements vernis est un peu obligé
patrick bruel à l'école as-tu jouer au
docteur avec tes copains
plus avec mes copines avec un ami
espagnol
les affaires françaises
as-tu enfermer des élèves de sexe
féminin dans les cabinets nom bizarre
moi c'est comme ça bah oui pourquoi tu
aurais pu s'enfermer avec elle mais pour
le pr nisand faire
ensuite on soit tu menti de devenir une
star non mais il a dit qu'il était un
état ça marche
as-tu renier certains de tes amis n'ont
pas aimé gré tu le vois plus
comme ça
as-tu faire donner tes ennemis
pas toujours quand tu es devenu une star
as-tu profiter de sa notoriété pour
obtenir des avantages particuliers
et voilà on y est
on est en plein dans la rubrique
fellation groupe est allongée
exactement ce qu'ils voulaient éviter il
voulait pas répondre si si j'ai obtenu
des avantages particuliers par le fait
d'être connu en effet mais je n'ai pas
spécialement cherché à la tuer chante
des chansons anciennes pour défaire des
plus vieilles
tu profiter de sa notoriété pour exiger
des pratiques contre nature
pas de préciser charles et jérémy
comment tu parle à dieu
séparation c'est au moins un quart
d'heure
toi tu n'as peur et camarade
patrick me oui tu est il arrivé de
refuser de faire l'amour en prétextant
une migraine oui
arrêté
lee goren arrêtés et ils arrivent et
d'absorber des substances illicites
avant de faire l'amour
non le peuple pas non jamais non non non
non j'ai jamais essayé ça non
est ce que tu te reposes me suis jamais
pendu vient ce happening
jacques vergès vous avez disparu entre
1966 et
1978 oui il n'avait jamais dit vous
étiez on a dit vous étiez chez polpot un
copain de fac à vous on a dit que vous
étiez avec le terroriste carlos vous
allez nous dire ce soir ma vie privée et
ma vie privée c'est la mienne comme le
votre vie privée est la vôtre je vous
demande que je demande à personne ce
qu'ils ont fait la nuit du relais des
deux dernières nuits du dernier week-end
en mai huit ans jacques basset tasser et
une nuits qui a été prolongé
à servion jugement dernier
[Musique]
jean d'ormesson
1 tu utilisé sa notoriété pour séduire
je crois que me suis servi des femmes
ouais pour être connu ouais et ensuite
je me suis servi ce que j'étais connu
pour avoir des femmes
jean d'ormesson
as-tu consommé des substances
aphrodisiaques
hélas pas suffisamment
[Musique]
jean d'ormesson as-tu pêcher en
accomplissant l'acte d'amour sans
volonté de procréer
c'est ce qu'il faut dire la vérité bah
au jugement dernier oui
d'accord on a compris
jean d'ormesson
as-tu pêcher à la mouche
à la bouche jean d'ormesson as tu envie
d'une jeune cousine
oui secret défense
jean d'ormesson
as-tu plus durant son existence à la
communauté homosexuelle
grâce à dieu oui
comment je me rappelle que
les y raconte on entre nous face à kas
est entre nous
alors moi je ne voulais pas ruiner d'un
coup tout le capital de sympathie que je
me suis attirée je ne suis pas
homosexuel mais évidemment j'ai beaucoup
plus à les homosexuels qui ont été les
amis très chers à moi que j'ai beaucoup
aimé et quelquefois j'ai été obligé de
courir un peu dans la salle de bain
et autour de nous autant de la cuisine
s'est arrêté là jean d'ormesson as tu
regardé tf1 le samedi soir
il m'est même arrivé le regarder
thalassa il est arrivé le tout regarder
jean d'ormesson
as tu déjà eu envie de te suicider
je me suis toujours arrêter le sur cette
pente parce que je pense que le suicide
ratée est une chose très ridicule
jean d'ormesson as tu déjà cru que dieu
n'existait pas pire quelques fois je me
suis allé jusqu'à croire qu'il existait
jean d'ormesson as-tu commis le péché de
mensonges en répondant à ces questions
oui bien sûr justement t-il j'en appelle
à l'assistance l'enfer ou le paradis
parfait
[Musique]
olala dire les loupiotes vers les jeunes
est est ce que tu crois en dieu oui
dernier geste as tu peur d'aller en
enfer sur le câble
c'est à l'enfer bah ouais super peur
as tu déjà regardé tf1 le samedi soir
fait peur
oui tous les samedis soirs as tu déjà
regardé un film porno en y prenant du
plaisir
je dire la vérité
là c'est le jugement dernier à mon avis
tu allais way
après quoi l'euro c'était moi j'ai pas
c'est un truc dans un escalier c'est fou
l'effet que ça fait les escaliers est
malaisé skalli c'est un fantasme être
terrible avec un ascenseur athènes
[ __ ] de palier
si ça va devenir sur une autre chaîne et
de se faire traiter de cochons
couvées de grosses pompes yann les
prochaines ne faillit jamais véronique
genest
as tu déjà pensé à épouser navarro pour
faire 60 % de part de marché
non parce qu'on serait pas qu'il fait as
tu déjà menti sur son âge oh oui alors
n'arrête pas d'ailleurs tu t'es planté
tout à l'heure tu as plus c'est pas
monsieur paradis va mentir la prochaine
question c'est pas de moi c'est de allah
a tué inciter des gens à manger du porc
non mais tu veux dire par inciter à
manger du porc de la pub pour du jambon
assez ça en fait
c'est l'heure du jugement dernier
jean hétu près pas encore mais bon
genre oui as tu cru en moi
à une époque oui pourquoi as-tu cessé de
croire en moi gens
parce que j'ai cessé parce que j'y ai
cru en vous par trouille de la mort et
je sais que vous n'arrangerait rien là
haut
tu fais chier jean jean
as-tu déjà pêché par penser par action
par omission ou à la mouche
pêcher à la mouche jamais
par omission jamais ai pas repensé tout
le temps
genre
tu foutu en l'air un tournage en
prétextant un quelconque mal au dos
non j'ai foutu en l'air un tournage en
prétextant une douleur dans le périnée
qui est située entre l'anus et les
testicules
genre tu veux à st
jean
as-tu déjà participé à des émissions de
télévision sous l'emprise de substances
illicites
non mais ce soir j'aurais dû
jean
as-tu déjà regardé tf1 le samedi soir en
deuxième partie de soirée non non jamais
pourvu que ça dure
tu déjà commis l'acte de chair sans
volonté reproductrices
oui de nombreuses fois les gens gardent
un souvenir est pas tant la plaie jean
desailly une époque
à bien des genres
as-tu déjà trompé ta maîtresse
non je ne suis pas un trompeur j'ai eu
des grandes passions mais je ne trompais
pas je partais est ce que tu te reposes
tous tes péchés gens non c'était le plus
agréable
[Musique]
judith godrèche as tu joue au docteur
avec tes copains à l'école
oui
à l'époque
as-tu péché par penser aux par action
ouais j'ai volé des bonbons ah mais
c'est tout un joueur a doctor
as-tu pêcher à la mouche à la mouche à
la boucle à mouches
à la mouche
non au oui non l'asticot je crois à
terry tu as tes chances
judith godrèche as tu déjà convoité
l'homme d'autrui ouais et hualan jamais
c'est vrai l'homme d'autrui jamais
as tu déjà commis le péché d'adultère
non
[Musique]
si enfin quand j'avais 13 ans devant lui
c'était un garçon s'appelle crise tant
que tu connais que tu connais la
pression car mais
j'étais avec lui mais je suis à 13 ans
marina mon cul c'est pas
du coucher pas à 13 ans
non non et mais non il y avait un autre
gars sont un peu vrai mais j'ai juste
fait ce match croit gilles godrèche as
tu déjà commis l'acte de chair sans
volonté reproductrices
oui as tu déjà penser à un juppé de
manière sexuelle
n'ont par contre quand j'étais petit je
faisais un rêve jacques martin ne
poursuivaient dans la forêt avec une
piqûre
judith a su profiter de sa notoriété
pour draguer des garçons non le dernier
ep les garçons qu'il faut si tu fais
semblant d'être occupés pour ne pas
donner d'argent un sdf non non je sais
pas simuler en fait oh c'est parce que
à l'époque
as
tu essayé pour échapper aux paparazzi de
te cacher derrière les oreilles de dany
boon
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater le il
a l'habitude abonnez vous il mettait un
peu de bleu